[Music]
you might be using your iPhone 24/7 but
there are still some things that you
don't know about some of these hacks are
just surprising and some of them could
also change the way you use your phone
make sure you watch this video until the
end to understand why you can sometimes
accept or decline a call and then you
can only slide to answer if this is your
first time visiting this channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you ten new secret phone
settings that will surprise you the
hidden information we bet that none of
you knew about this setting because the
only way to use this is to know the
specific codes that you need to call to
get more information about your phone
one of these codes is star 3 0 0 1 pound
1 2 3 4 5 pound star enter the number
and press the call button to have access
to what we call the iPhone field mode
one of the best features is being able
to see a more detailed signal strength
indicator in the top left hand corner it
goes from negative 140 which represents
no signal at all to negative 40 which is
the maximum strength if you don't
believe us just try it yourself on your
phone the text shortcuts now this is the
best setting if you ever want to save
time or waste time by making fun of your
friends you have already seen people
turning a simple word into something
really stupid and see people going crazy
during a conversation and it is actually
really easy to do this go to Settings
General keyboard and text replacements
then you will be able to create your own
shortcuts for example you can use a code
like atmail and ask your phone to
transform it into your email address so
you won't have to write it every time
you can also steal your friends phone
and transform hi into a random word like
pickle you'll have a lot of fun with
this new setting the head control if you
are tired of using your fingers to
control your phone just like everyone
else you'll be happy to hear that you
can use your head too you simply need to
go to Settings General accessibility and
switch control this is how you're going
to be able to add a new camera switch
so that's an action you want the head
movement to control for example
increasing or decreasing the volume then
you will see blue bars appear around the
frame of the iPhone display then tilt
your head and watch the magic happen
just make sure that you won't move your
head too much when you listen to music
or you might have some problems with the
volume the battery this is one of the
most terrifying things that we see every
day we receive a notification reading
that there is only 10% battery left and
we don't know what we are going to do
without the love of our life but you'll
be happy to hear that there is a way to
prevent that first go to settings and
then battery this is where you will have
the option to use your phone in low
power mode to make sure that your iPhone
uses less energy during the day you can
also see the battery usage of the last
24 hours in the last seven days to see
if it would be a good idea to change
your habits a little bit and here's
another day saved by these settings the
location this setting might be a little
bit scary because you will discover that
your phone always knows where you are if
you go to settings privacy location
services system services and frequent
locations you can see where you used
your phone in the past month you can
also let your friends and family members
know where you are by sharing your
location in the messages app look at the
conversation look at the details and
click on share my location then you can
tell them where you are for one hour
until the end of the day or indefinitely
it's a good idea to tell your friends
where you are if you meet a stranger but
don't give this information to that
person you don't know the vibration you
have probably heard of personalized
ringtone to know which of your friends
they're calling but you can do the same
thing with vibrations and the only limit
is your imagination go to settings
sounds ringtone vibrations create new
vibration then you will have the chance
to tap a vibration pattern on the screen
go to your contacts and edit the one you
want the vibrations set for this is how
you'll know who is texting you without
looking at your voting
you probably won't care if the girl for
the team project is texting you but
you'll know that you have to answer if
your crush sends you a message the
accessibility there are tons of things
you can discover on your phone and some
of them are more useful than others
start by going to Settings General and
accessibility this is where you'll see a
lot of options for example voiceover can
read everything you see on your iPhone
but it will also change the way you use
it you can also use a zoom or a
magnifier by clicking three times on the
home button and there are also some
random things you can do like invert
colors or use a color filter this one
might not be really useful but you could
use it as a surprising prank if your
friend ever lets you play with their
phone the notifications sometimes you
don't have any notification and we feel
lonely and then there are too many and
we feel too popular don't worry there is
a way to deal with that open your phone
and swipe up to reveal different options
then click on do not disturb which is
represented by a moon this is how you
won't receive any notification if you
were in bed in class or at a meeting you
can even go to settings and do not
disturb to schedule when you want to use
this option it's perfect if you know
that you are going to be sleeping from
10 p.m. to 7 a.m.
however just don't forget to look at
your phone to make sure that you won't
miss anything
it's a photo we think that we are using
our iPhone more for selfies than we do
for phone calls unfortunately it is
sometimes hard to press the button when
you have the perfect pose or stand
further from the camera this is why this
little hack is really useful you can use
the volume to take a picture and the
best thing about this is that you can do
it by using the headphones cord to it is
also fun to know that you can still take
a picture even when you are filming a
video with these new settings we're
pretty sure that you are going to be the
one who takes the best selfies on
Instagram
the call have you ever been wondering
why you can accept or decline a call and
then you can only swipe to answer iPhone
users had many theories to explain this
difference some of them think that it
depends on who is calling or which phone
they are using but the answer is
actually really simple when your phone
is locked you can only slide to answer
but if you are already using it you have
the option to accept or decline who knew
that it was this simple are there any
other secret phone settings that you
know don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comment section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for tech news secret phone settings
that will surprise you for more stories
like this make sure you watch fifteen
ways the Internet has changed your life
thanks for watching
[Music]